hi guys it's Liam here and this is the
wired autocomplete interview to answer
this I'm excited I'm really excited
about this here we go let's see what
happens who is Liam Payne I asked myself
this question every single day I don't
know the I'm still I'm still trying to
figure it out
who is Liam Payne Game of Thrones now
this one I got dragged into this before
and as someone called sir pain or
someone who's not Liam Payne but I often
get compared to him but he's like the
guy who like chops people's heads off I
don't think people like him very much
but I got halfway through Game of
Thrones I just caught I couldn't keep up
and when Ned Stark dying I was like why
am I even watching this anymore like I
can't deal oh sorry that'll be quick who
is liam payne's best friend who is my
best friend
I mean I'm gonna say my girlfriend's my
best friend who does Liam Payne support
which I support
I mean football team support is West
Brom but I haven't been for very long
time so I'm not really a very good
support I but that's who I support I
support my legs and my legs support me
getting aggressive thank you very much
what does me and Payne's tattoo say I
have one that says only time will tell I
have one that says somewhere is a place
that nobody knows one that says I
figured it out and one on this arm that
says everything I wanted but nothing
I'll ever need it but I think that's all
all of them the tattoo that draws the
most attention is probably these arrows
which I mean was just a really drunken
idea of just wanting to get a tattoo and
just going for it
what is liam payne's favorite food
I think pizza because you can just
pizzas just the bet you can't really go
wrong with pizza it's so good
could we get pizza what did Liam Payne
gave Charlie puth I've always been quite
good friends with Charlie I mean we
don't speak as often as we should as his
song to say we don't talk anymore sought
out Charlie I gave to Charlie puth a
gift of a t-shirt which had me a little
tiny me in the pocket which yes she was
really fun with the war on stage when we
were performing at a radio show that we
had together but I love Charlie he's so
so great and he gave me a really great
song so I mean you know the
was a good deal what is Liam Payne music
I suppose my music is R&B pop maybe I
mean a dance downloader different genres
when I made like the first few records
just trying different things out music
for me is definitely evolving as I get
older and also as I figure out more
about what I want to do rather than
listening to loads of different opinions
about stuff and I mean I had such great
success with the first song that I did
and you know my latest single stuck it
up was written by the same people who
did strip that down which was Ed Sheeran
and
Steve Mac which are just some of the
best people in the game so I mean really
sport for choice on the different
songwriters and people that I've got to
work we've been having
ed Sheeran write your songs it's just
the biggest confidence build in the game
so thanks ed what is Liam Payne doing
now it's very specific isn't it I'm
figuring out why you Google what I was
doing that and what was I do it at the
moment that you googled out who knows
when is liam payne's birthday my
birthday is the 29th of August my zodiac
sign is Virgo
I actually I must start getting to
horoscopes a little bit more no it's
only called horoscopes amazing it starts
with horror I don't wanna so I don't
know a lot about virgos but I think I
overthink everything
what color are liam payne's eyes what's
funny about this is my eyes look like
they're brown but when we did the wax
work for the Madame Tussauds thing in
the UK they have a thing where they look
at your eyes in a certain light and then
they figure out the color of its and
match-ups of the thing the mime were
actually more green than they were brown
which even I didn't know that so I don't
they're like hazely green sort of candy
and painting it's been known to happen
sometimes yeah sometimes they come
sometimes I really can't this morning
forget about it can Liam Payne dance can
you know no to throw the odd shape from
time to time I like when we used to do
choreography but I just don't think it's
very much me anymore
and it scares me as well I I get so shy
dance in front of people there's like a
staged dance which I feel like when I
watched George Michael and and it was
also Robbie Williams perform it's like a
certain Bob that they do that if you
fall into that groove then you just
she's saved through the whole experience
so I've always kind of draw myself
towards that doesn't Liam Payne have a
kid yes I have one child whose name is
bear and he is the most wonderful thing
ever there was a whole day where he was
like they do this thing where like
babies all clear fluid off their lungs
and he was all days going like this like
growling it everyone and then the next
day the nurse came in and she was like
oh how was it little bear doing this
morning and it just seemed to fit
perfectly and share all kind of really
fell in love with it so we went with it
fatherhood changed me dramatically I
think it gives you the chance to be a
better person I think it also made me
afraid of loads of different things that
I was not scared of before like doing
stunts and heights and all sorts of
different things I was never really
afraid of whereas now that you have a
child your life's really not your own so
you can't really take the same sort of
chances that you used to so I feel like
that's one of the ways it definitely
changed you the most it makes you switch
on to a lot more stuff for sure is Liam
Payne a daddy I am a daddy
there's some sort of hidden to do with
the laughter in the room I feel like
there's some sort of hidden hidden think
about it but I was always known as the
dad at the band so I've literally been
called daddy since I was like 19 which
can really throw you off but the thing
is unlike Twitter it just gets more and
more of people calling you daddy which
is it meant to be some form of kink I
guess I just don't know what to say
about it because I am a daddy yearbook
in that way
am I gonna be yours I'm glad we cleared
that up it's been it's been a long old
time about him is Liam Payne Australia I
would like to confirm that I'm not
actually Australia why why would I be
Australia not without being like
partially would like offensive to
Australian people is Liam Payne from one
direction I am I mean at the moment we
seem to just get asked all the time if
we are give are you getting back
together aren't you get a game out
together
the truth is I think it's a matter of
when at the moment everyone's super
comfortable doing their own thing and
everyone's really happy doing their solo
stuff you know I'm really enjoying this
the moment I've had great success doing
this at the moment which has been really
really fun it's great to watch everybody
else venturing out doing their own thing
so I mean it's more to do with where
some other people in the bands heads are
out with it to be honest with you so I
keep in touch with most of them I think
other people just want their space and
also you know we worked together for
five years but some of us we didn't
really have that much in common except
for that we had a job together now we
don't have that job together any longer
there's not really any real reason for
us to talk that often which is fine
that's just the way people are really so
it's not you're not going to get on it's
not that I don't get along with anyone
but you're not gonna be best friends
with everyone that's just not the way
life works unfortunately I mean watch
this space this who happens does Liam
Payne speak Spanish or lock it down
might be any good that's all I could say
and I can say all the words in familiar
but I really haven't got a clue what it
means I really like singing in Spanish
it's actually a lot of fun it's a
beautiful beautiful language gracias
does Liam Payne have siblings that I
know of I have two sisters no I have two
sisters
they've always really looked after me
and cared for me which is really really
cool so love and lots we have like a
little family group chat on on whatsapp
which is good we've purposely not let my
parents go on it so we can kind of just
like talk a little crap which is good
parents on the group chats just not
something that anybody needs really
especially not my parents we have
another how Liam Payne how is Liam Payne
[Laughter]
way why I'm good I'm ace life's life's
good right now I'm it's pretty perfect
so excited about the new release I'm
very happy in my personal life
so liam payne's liam payne's nice I'm
gonna stop say my names is weird how to
get Liam Payne hair I don't I don't know
I don't even know what to say to that
really just have hair any grows and it
how old is Liam Payne today I am 26
I wouldn't say 25 then was it was just
my birthday for 26 and I was quite
excited about turning 26 I kind of felt
like it was like coming of age sort of
moment I don't know you're closer to 30
than you are to 20 and that seems to be
a traumatic thing for me for some reason
everyone who's older than he looks at me
that year right but I don't know it just
feels like that sort of time I guess how
tall Liam Payne at all Liam Payne I am
exactly a hundred and eighty five
centimeters and I only know that because
we get measured for soups and things
quite a lot it's something like 6.08
something I know that because of Google
and you type in YT is 185 centimeters in
fee that's the kind of thing I Google I
think the questions that I've saw today
some of them are massively confusing I
don't know how you could think I was
Australia but I'm a person and or how
tall Liam Payne who knows
please keep googling about because I
really enjoy this and I definitely want
to come back and do it again at some
point we should do a really x-rated
version because I feel that there's a
lot more
I'll see you guys next time